les assassins se battent pour le libre arbitre
et leurs principaux rivaux sont les templiers et les
templiers essaient d'améliorer l'humanité
grâce à la science Je pense qu'Assassin's Creed
a un concept très profond, une idée
qui remonte dans le temps et a une
sorte de relation avec l'ancêtre
qui est venu  devant vous, le
voyage global du film se déroule à travers les yeux
de notre protagoniste, Michael
Fassbender jouant votre passé,
il commence à apprendre qu'il vient d'une
lignée d'assassins, il réalise la
véritable histoire de lui-même et il crée une
sorte de révolution
ce soir, nous sommes  le
marché des assassins est l'un des plus grands acteurs de
sa génération et il y a beaucoup d'autres
personnages forts dans le
film Assassin's Creed l'univers est une
expérience cinématographique dont les
séquences d'action sont massives je voulais juste
être un tour incroyable
vous devez lui montrer qui il vraiment  est
toi